The Joe Rogan experience.
Just as a reminder,
I want to give props to American
airlines for returning my luggage. Oh,
after the whole weekend and they missed
that fucking half ounce of weed in my
boxing glove. So you're the
delivery driver. You were dumb.
Fuck that. They lost my
movie tie bag. They did.
I was going to Columbus to go to the
short movie thigh and I brought in the uh,
you know my little fucking shin
pads and my gloves is some ad raps.
He'd been doing that a lot lately. Huh?
More than I love it. It's great. Right?
I go twice a week. Well I've had, I'm 56,
the targets that thing and I take
the class where everybody else,
I do everything else. I die
and I go don't want boxing.
Cause Tuesday and Wednesday,
Tuesday and Thursdays boxing.
Now when you do the class,
did they have you spar?
I'm 56 cause I light no
headgear. Tapping pop. Yeah,
working in a combination shit like
that. Saturday, Sundays I go in,
there's an open mat. If I'm home,
I go on in is a chick that's
like an ice cop, an ice cop.
Oh no. You know she's, she's
a tough chick. Yeah. Yeah.
She trains for Brett and the whole thing.
If I go down and just let her beat
me up to death. Let me ask you this.
As someone who was born
in another country,
how do you think that they should
handle the immigrations that are here?
Because this is the big question. A
lot of people know people that are,
I mean probably a lot of people listening
know someone who they love that's
illegal.
Whether they're illegal from Canada or
they're illegal from Europe or they're
illegal from Mexico, where the fuck,
there's a lot of people that get over
here and stay over here that aren't
supposed to be. Some of them turn
out, turn out to be amazing people.
So how do you decide,
how do you decide who gets to say and to
someone coming over here and trying to
make their life better? A better
thing, but just doing it illegally.
Does that automatically discount them
from staying here? That seems crazy.
What if they're great.
There's a lot of people come over here
because they were super unfortunate and
where they were born, they, they,
they grew up in a shitty place
and they wanted to make it better,
but they didn't know how to do it.
So they came over to
America by hook or by crook.
They figured out how to get here. They
got here and now they're kicking ass.
Why? Why would you want
to get rid of them?
As long as they're not
criminals that hurting anybody.
Why would you want to get rid of
them? Well, start is, let's do this.
That's what's going on right now.
Just points the finger
at a certain realm of,
Oh, you're pointing the finger South
of the border. Yeah. It's Canadian.
A lot of Canadian. Which, and I'm
not saying nothing bad about anybody.
This is the United States of America.
People come here to fucking have a dream.
Yeah. And whatever happens, bro,
sometimes a dream goes caput. You know,
when I went to New York,
I spent three weeks in New York and I
Ubered and I did a little thing in my
mind, you know, I took 20 Ubers.
In fact I became Uber platinum
because I was doing, you know,
all of these rides, not one
white person picked me up,
not one time. And guess
what? I asked questions,
I asked everybody questions
and the most inspiring
person I met was one that I worked
though. I rapped at six 30 in the morning.
There was no way I was getting in the
van to go home and I just called Uber.
I was Ridgewood, Brooklyn and
this Indian girl picked me up.
Very cute, you know, six
in the fucking morning,
it's still kind of dark out, you
know, five 30 whatever it was.
And this little girl that
weighed 90 pounds picked me
up, got in the car, hello?
We have charger in the back if you want
to charge your car and there's little
caramels in the front, you know.
And I said, where are you from?
And she told me India and I go, how long
have you been here? A year and a half.
Spoke perfect English.
Wow. I go, why do you,
why did you become a little bit drive?
But she doesn't became Uber driver
because I was a wasted something Indian
restaurant and the guy abused me and he
would only pay me eight bucks an hour
and take half my tips. So me
and my cousins got together.
We put away money and we
rent a car. We leased a car,
my S she drives in the daytime
and I drive with at night. Wow.
And I drag on, why do you, aren't you
scared to go? I at? And she's like, no.
She's like, I love it because
there's no traffic in it.
Mm. I go, what do you walk with? I just
asked her creepy questions. Not sad.
Yeah. And it was, I went, I gave her
an extra tip like, let me see this.
Can you be illegal and do that?
Did they check your citizenship? I, I
don't know what the status was with her.
I didn't ask her. I didn't know if she
made me any, but what do you think?
Do you think that you could
do that? Do you think?
Like if you came from another car,
you came from Guatemala illegally,
you were came over here though and became
an Uber driver. Could you do that? Me?
No. Can anybody do that or did
they check your citizenship?
What do you think Jamie?
There's, yes, they can do that.
So someone definitely can come over
here and start working for Uber or,
or another or a similar, yeah.
I'm not saying that I'm
doing that necessarily,
like through the proper ways that
you can, if you have a legal friend,
you can use their license to be the,
like the Uber thing and they
don't know who's behind the car.
So it happens all the time.
When I'm ordering food,
you will, you definitely have to have
a valid driver's license, right? Yeah.
When you get a valid driver's
license, if you're illegal.
Oh, that's the part. Like,
so I'm saying so like, no,
but that doesn't stop someone from
getting behind a car if you don't have a
license any day.
That's sort of where I'm going with
someone to getting in trouble right now is
on we on the shit list because we
agreed in somebody else to give illegals
licenses. That's why I was asking,
there was a thought that popped a memory
that popped into my head about some
story like that,
that they were going to give a
illegal aliens the right to drive.
I'm sort of saying like ed does happen
but not above the board basically.
Cause it's, yeah, but are you sure?
Could you see if they're trying to
give illegal aliens driver's licenses?
Cause I remember a story
like this too as well.
People were super upset
about it. It's a weird man.
States that allow it. There you go,
baby. Where do you have to move? What are
those States in DC?
Uh, California is the first one
as of 2013 Colorado, Connecticut,
Delaware, everywhere. Their
suite. Hawaii, Illinois,
Maryland, Nevada, New
Mexico. Your interests.
Yeah, everywhere. There's weed.
Hawaii doesn't necessarily have Vermont.
I think Hawaii is very close
to that business standpoint.
They work for cheaper and work
harder than, you know. I mean,
there's so many benefits to as a
business owner and different, I mean,
when was the last time you saw
a white laborer? You see him,
you go in the kitchen and at any
restaurant it's all you know.
I mean, and so now you, now you,
you questioning what rights you
have as an American. You come here,
you got a job, you're working
hard, you stay out of trouble,
you stay out of trouble, you mind your
business, you know, I mean, I grew up,
you and I grew up in the East coast
where you go to a Chinese restaurant and
you'd see them,
the husband and wife working and the
kids would be doing homework at the back
table. And if you came in the
daytime, it was a different couple,
which is telling me that
two couples got together,
they buy a home and they opened a
business together and they work together.
That's what those immigrant groups do.
And then from there they bring
a cousin and they open the open.
And next thing you know,
they got three houses on the block and
now he just had a fucking immigrant
family move into your neighborhood.
Not necessarily good or bad.
You know what I'm saying? That that nice.
We all had them in our neighborhoods.
Sure. I remember 70 years ago,
this is your grandparents,
so you have to think
about your grandparents.
How would you want them to treat it?
I'm sure your grandpa father got a job,
lame Rick way before he
got his immigration papers.
I don't know how they did it right.
I think they got it pretty quick.
You get through Ellis Island
and they push boy shoot drew.
I mean the legal situation, it
was a different world back then.
You could immigrate pretty easily.
Like my grandparents weren't rocket
scientists when they came over here.
They were kids. They're there,
their parents weren't geniuses.
Do you know what's going on with farmers?
Do you know what's going on in South
America right now? Nicaragua, Honduras,
all those places. Pure hell, pure hell.
You know, I can't be mad at you for
wanting to get the fuck out of there,
but there's other places
on earth right now. Well,
this PO fucking hell going on. Yeah,
there's places trying to come over to,
let's point everybody out. Let's
lock all the fucking borders.
Don't make it seem like it's just
Mexico. That's the fucking problem.
You know, we're getting
bombarded from everywhere.
We'll get new people in here every day
from everywhere. I ain't mad at it.
They come in here to make better lives,
but don't just keep pointing
the fucking water that you know.
Who else is coming through that Mexican
border that nobody's about. Jamie,
when you get a minute, if you'd
love to check it, just to verify me.
You know how many Cubans and getting sent
back to cube on a daily basis from New
Mexico? Really getting back to go shot.
But Cubans when they come to a why they're
not coming through, they're closed,
all that type of shit. What? So right
now you can't come through Miami.
It's easier to come. Go from Cuba
to Mexico and just join the walk.
Whoa. And walk up. But once that happens
are in America, we give them asylum.
Right? Right. The tag. But does that still
going on? I think RO Bama removed it.
Did he really? Yes.
Trump made it so we can't go over there
and then you go [inaudible] pack Mexican
shelters hoping people
are going through Mexico.
That's crazy. I think I the
lumber a couple of weeks ago,
I think 900 Cubans are getting
sent back weekly to get shot.
Does you think more people,
more people or make it towards the border
since Trump was like, build that wall,
build that wall.
Do you think more people are headed
towards the border now because it's just
like it's a popular thing to
do. It's a part of our culture.
A part of the conversation
is the border wall, right?
Like do you want a border wall or do you
not want to build that wall and make it
a fucking million feet high, bring
it right to that top of the earth.
Or are you one of those people that
thinks anybody should be able to come over
here and have a better
life? You know, and this,
those two ideas of fucking
clashing left and right.
Some people think that people
should be able to try to do better,
try to better themselves. They
should have the opportunity.
And then some people think, fuck
them, you were born somewhere else.
You don't ever get a chance
to come over here, go,
go in through proper channels,
which is almost impossible.
Do something that's very valuable to
us over here. See, that's the thing.
Like if you're a person who has
some extraordinary skill, you know,
you could probably get American
citizenship easier, you know, unusual.
If you contributing to the
physics department at Harvard
or something like that
and you're, you know, you were
born in Germany or wherever,
you probably get citizenship a little
bit quicker than you're just a guy who
like lives in Guatemalan,
wants to come to America because
he thinks he can advance his life.
You think he can get better,
whereas where he lives, there's no,
you can't go anywhere. You're
stuck. The poverty is extreme.
The crimes extreme and he wants
none of that. He wants to do better.
So he makes it over here. I'm like,
listen, when you talk about immigration,
you're going to get good and
bad from every show. You know,
Castro was 79 opened up this prisons in
the Mario and you got 100,000 Cubans and
I'm like a thousand fucking spoiled rotten
savages from Cuban prisons where they
were no clothes and this,
they have to shit in a hole in the
middle of the floor. This averages,
they're animals.
They got no problem taking your
life from a piece of toilet paper.
But the same one's true
from other countries.
We get the good and the bad
from other country, you know,
let's not beat around the Bush before
Russians come here, they got a course,
they go to a school and to take the 12
week course on how to come and get money
right off the bat. How did I go to
social security? Check that out, Jamie.
That's a very weird one.
They get taught how to come
here and scam the system.
Whether you want to call a scan,
I'm not putting nobody down.
I have a tons of Russian friends. I
love them. I'm not saying them bad,
but I've heard that's a fact.
I've heard them from them.
I have a friend who's married and she
told me one day that before they come
here, they'd take a course to
prep them on how to get money.
As soon as they land, three days
after they get them, they land.
They get caching and Dola
paperwork. What to say?
They coach. That's hilarious. It's
like a service that they offer. Yeah.
Some type of class, the system works, but,
but if you want to send the system,
they'll tell you how to do it.
That's how many Armenians come
over. Come over, get citizenship.
Guess what they do?
They get social security and they move
back to our meeting and they get the
check sent back to our media. They
have a system on how to do that.
They've got a thousand loopholes now,
brother. And if you learn those loopholes,
you could cave the fucking system.
There's nothing wrong with having a
group of people that all agree on certain
rules, right. Which is what
the United States should be.
But the problem with having
a group of people is you,
you don't get to pick
like who's in that group.
So you just deciding instead of being
admitted by your merit or how how good a
neighbor you are or how nice of
a person you are. Now you just,
whether or not you were
born on the dirt like that,
were you born on this dirt or that
dirt cause you're born on that dirt.
You can't stay. But if
you're born on this dirt,
even if you're a shit human
being, you get to hang out,
you get to ruin other people's
lives while you're here.
As long as you don't do enough
that we need to put you in a cage.
And then if we do,
we keep you for a couple of years
and let you out and you do more.
I mean this is, we have no problem
with that. I don't know what, uh,
what the percentage is. What
the fuck was I going? I dunno.
I almost thought it was what you said
is a good people versus bad people that
come in to across the
border. The thing is,
every time there's a bad one
that comes across the border,
it's highlighted as an example of why we
got to keep the border closed and they
have a point. They all
have a point. Absolutely.
When you see someone who is
talking about illegal gang members,
they're sneaking across the
border and murdering people,
it absolutely has happened. It's
100% of a real thing. This is not,
not fiction questions. How
much does it happen? And uh,
how much better is it for those
people's lives that make it across?
Is there a way to screen better to make
sure that the bad people don't come in
and all of these questions
are legitimate. You know,
you don't want a bunch of fucking evil
vicious people from another country in
your neighborhood. That's how everybody
feels. You don't want your children,
your family to be in danger because
someone's knock across the border and they
have a long history of working
for the cartel, murdering people.
That's a real thing.
That's a real possibility.
So all the people that are vigilant, all
the people that are scared, you know,
they're probably smart to be scared.
Look at fucking human history.
People are capable of doing some awful
shit. No one's saying I'm not. I
don't think there should be no,
no wall at all. Nothing stopping
people from coming across.
You definitely don't want
pieces of shit coming over here.
That's how I find out. Did you ever
notice that? Maybe we'll full. Yeah,
we're probably, maybe we'll fall.
Did you notice that when you go on,
there's homeless people on Ventura
fucking Boulevard on Lankershim Boulevard
under bridges everywhere. Has that ever
come to your mind that a way you go,
there's cars everywhere and the
between Uber and Lyft and cabs,
now there's trafficking. Every major
fucking city. There's lock or whatever.
Did you give notice that?
Maybe it's not that I hate Cubans or
Mexicans or Puerto Ricans or blacks and
Germans. Irish maybe
that will fucking fall.
Have you ever come to that conclusion?
Yeah, we're just full right now. Yeah.
We have to take five years off. Like I
would accept that. I would accept that.
I would accept special circumstances,
like why are you have family
here? But at this point right now,
we'll fucking fall. We'll fall.
We don't have nowhere else to put anymore.
We really don't look at eddies unless
we pack them all to Iowa and send them
all, you know, send them all into my,
where's the highest population
of Mexicans in the country?
I would probably say Southern California.
Wrong. Indiana. Chicago. Chicago.
Yeah. Hi. They farm a ton
of shit up in Chicago,
Illinois. You know, where's the
highest population of Puerto Ricans?
The Bronx. You're wrong. Cleveland
clinic. Because in the 50s they shipped,
they all the dealers were with uh,
taking Puerto Ricans and
putting them to the Cleveland,
Ohio area to work in the fucking
Ford plants and all those plants.
And after all those places sat down,
all those people sitting
there holding on to that Dick.
When you go to certain parts where Ohio,
there's a suburb outside of Cleveland,
12 fucking Puerto Rican. Wow.
You know, interesting. But it's,
I don't think of it as we hate
Russians or German and Chinese.
I look at it from a different spread back
through the times and maybe will flow,
you know,
it's for me to send my daughter
to date cam cost rebills a week.
I'm not complaining. It's a great day.
Kids a science camp, they make potions.
They learn about light
bulbs and electricity.
My point is I did the same
thing for free when I was a kid.
All I had to do was walk to my
park. There's no funds left.
There's nothing left for
these kids. You know,
I dunno when I walk into
a Dodger game or an event,
I go,
I always think of the family of four in
America today that both parents have to
work. Yeah. And everybody has to work.
If you go by my office with a podcast in
the middle, is that a 24 hour daycare?
And many times I'll leave my office at
midnight and I see parents picking up
their kids, carrying them out over
their shoulders into that car. You know,
at the cost a lot to control the American
family. There's not a lot of jobs.
Why didn't you see everybody's
driving Uber? If you take Uber.
Uber's is interesting. I'm
thinking of doing a documentary.
I'm just going overs and talking to these
people and ask them why they're Uber.
Yesterday I had an engineer
engineer lost his job.
58 years old, got to work. Asian fellow.
Very nice. I've tipped him extra. He
offered me to plug the phone. I mean,
you know. Yeah. You have to
look at that and go, wow,
that's a lot of people in
this country without work.
There's a lot of fucking homeless people
and we're running out of money to take
care of what we got here.
[inaudible].